كميه البيانات التي نصدرها عن طريق اجراء
المدفوعات الرقميه اضافه للبيوت الذكيه
والسيارات المجهزه بالكاميرات قد تجعل
الخصوصيه شيئا من الماضي ومع تتبع سلوكيات
المستخدمين وضعت شركه كاسبر سكي تصورا
يحمل مزيدا من الرقمنه في عام 2023 ونصائح
للحفاظ على الخصوصيه الخبراء توقعوا مزيدا
من الاعلانات الموجهه لنا المبنيه على
سلوكياتنا خاصه من شركات مواقع التواصل
والتسوق مثل متى وامازون وجوجل لكن هذه
الشركات تظل امنه على الخصوصيه بالنسبه
للمواقع الاصغر كما ان الهواتف الذكيه
ستحل بشكل اكبر بدل المستندات الورقيه بل
وستكون بديلا ايضا للبطاقات المصرفيه
البلاستيكيه في بعض البلدان كذلك ظهور
المزيد من المخاوف حول خصوصيه عالم
الميتافيرس الذي لبعض بانها قائمه اصلا
بوجود الهواتف الذكيه وانترنت الاشياء